- Hi, I'm Lana Condor
and I play Lara Jean.
- And I'm Noah Centineo
and I play Peter Kavinsky.
- And I'm Israel Broussard
and I play Josh Anderson.
- We're going to find out
which characters we are--
- From To All the Boys I've Loved Before.
- Only on Netflix.
(upbeat music)
- So choose a carb to
bring to the bake sale.
We've got cookies, always a nice option.
Cupcakes.
- [Lana] Yum.
- [Israel] Brownies.
- [Lana] Yes.
- [Israel] Donuts.
Muffins and last but not least, pie.
I'm going to go with the brownies
because chocolate never fails.
- I want good cupcakes
'cause then you can cut
them in half, flip them,
and have a cupcake sandwich--
- Be your own person, Lana.
- I'm gonna--
- You're gonna, oh.
- I'm like trying to cheat (laughs).
No, I'm going with pie.
Your friend cancels plans
last minute on a Friday night.
What is your plan B?
Stay home and watch a movie.
Text your other friends
to see what they're up to.
Go to a coffee shop to
quietly read a book.
Head to your favorite hang out spot.
Text your crush and see if
they want to grab dinner.
Or go to the gym for a quick
workout. That's not mine.
- I'm gonna say hang out spot.
- I'm gonna go to a coffee
shop and read a book.
That's what--
- And hopefully get stared at.
Stay at home and watch a movie.
Probably a movie on Netflix.
(ding ding)
- Which accessory would you
purchase for your bedroom?
This fun quilt.
These bold plant pots.
These statement wall tapestries.
This beautiful candle, this cute planner,
or this pastel lamp.
- (stammering)
- Pastel.
- You said pastel
Like, you made it sound so regal.
- I mean, pastel in it's own rite,
is very,
- Regal.
- Right on.
- I'm gonna go with the fun quilt.
Keep warm, looks comfy.
- I love candles.
- But what does it smell like?
- But this candle, it's like a light blue
which means it's probably sweet,
and I don't like sweet candles.
- What do you,
- I want like a--
- Hint of lavender?
- Like a dark rum... smelling
- Oh okay so more of like a
- Woodsy.
- I'm gonna go with these bold plant pots
because even if there wasn't a plant in it
you could still use it for like
- Keys, change
- Pasta, soup
- Okay
- Pick an emoji that speaks to your soul
- I can't even do the flat face.
And then it's the kissy face.
And then it's the cry eyes
- That's not crying, that's laughing.
- But he's crying while he's laughing
- Have you never used--
- I use that one all the time
I understand where I messed up.
- The crying eyes...
- The crying eyes is this one.
Like the--
With the tears going down like this.
- With the stream, it's the
steady, like, waterfall.
- Waterfall.
- You're right. Alright? I'm wrong.
Is that what you wanted to hear?
- Yes.
- I want the glasses one.
- [Israel] So out of these
six, let's just label all--
- [Lana] Okay... you right, you right.
- I'm gonna go with the cry face.
Slash laugh face.
- Bottom left.
- I'm gonna go with this
one. That's just like...
- The top one? The first one?
Just the flat--
- 'Cause I feel like that's like,
I think I live my life
like, a little scared
and a little confused. And I think
this one really speaks to me.
And a little dead inside.
- You look hopeless.
- That is true. Just a little terrified.
(fake crying)
- Which song are you going to jam out to
on your drive home from school?
"Girls Like You" by Maroon 5
"Attention" by Charlie Puth
"In My Feelings" By Drake
Which one is that?
- Kiki, do you love me?
- Okay
"One Kiss" by Dua Lupa
"Sit Next To Me" by Foster The People
and "Solo" by Clean Bandit
What is that song?
- I wanna fup fup fup
but I'm broken hearted
(laughter)
- Oh that one, okay
- I've heard two of these songs because
I'm musically illiterate.
But, I'm gonna go with
"Attention" by Charlie Puth
- (Lana sings "Attention")
- 'Cause that's the one
I bounce to the most.
- That bassline, it's so good.
(mimics song)
That's not it.
(laughter)
Uh, I'm gonna go with "Solo"
- "One Kiss" is the uh--
- (Noah sings "One Kiss")
- That one, yeah that's
the one. "One Kiss".
- See, I'm getting a bunch of songs
I'm ridin solo, ridin solo
(laughter)
That's what I'm singing
- By Jason Derulo?
- Jason Derulo!
- Finally, choose a Korean
dish to gobble down.
Kimchi,
bibimbap,
I don't know how to
pronounce that, I'm sorry.
T-- Tteok?
- Are you sweating?
- A little bit.
- Are you nervous?
- [Noah] Bulgogi, Bossam,
or Japchae.
I only know what kimchi is.
- I'm gonna go with the bibimap.
- That's a good one.
- I pick kimchi.
- I got Peter.
- I got Chris.
- Yes!
- Wait--
I got Lara Jean.
And I actually, truly,
I wasn't doing that on purpose.
Kind, funny, and a little shy,
you have a big heart
and a lot of feelings.
Don't be afraid to wear
your heart on your sleeve
from time to time, and trust your instinct
when it comes to love.
- Confident, funny, and charming.
You put on a hard exterior, when
you're really a softie on the inside.
You care deeply about
your friends and family
and would go above and beyond
to be there if they needed you
- You feel like you're confident?
Do you feel like you're funny?
- Oh this is just a quiz.
- Do you feel like you're charming?
- I can be in the right instances,
but most of the time,
I'm charmingly like--
(crickets)
- Outgoing, funny, and deeply loyal.
You're someone who isn't afraid
to stand up for your beliefs
While sometimes your mouth
can get you into trouble,
- Yep.
- True. You wouldn't trade
your extroverted ways
for anything.
- Do you think you're an extrovert?
- I charge introvertedly, and then I like,
(snaps)
super out-going.
- He really has a great
grasp on his personality.
As you can tell.
- We actually talked about this,
like on set. We were like,
You could have played Peter, like
I could have played Josh.
Like it could have gone
either way we felt.
- You are Peter.
And I am--
I'm honored.
- Can I be a part of this?
- [Noah] I kinda wish that I was Josh.
(laughter)
(upbeat music)